thank you for that good afternoon
everybody i'm diane Russell I'm from the
forestry and biodiversity office at US
Agency for International Development I
had the privilege of being here for a
year in 2000 2001 so it's great to be
back I really enjoy seeing seeing all of
you meeting new people and catching up
with some old friends and I'm
particularly delighted to be moderating
this panel on reconciling interests at
the landscape scale I'm an
anthropologist who's worked across the
spectrum of these scales from food
security to landscape scale conservation
to agroforestry and the kind of
discussion that I think we want to
generate today is going to really focus
on how you know who are these various
interests that we're talking about what
are the scales that need to be
reconciled what are the mechanisms for
doing those what are the sort of
underlying issues that that that that
relate to all of the different sectors
and scales that we're talking about you
know things like land tenure and
property rights and governance and
markets and the broader trends that
we're seeing in society today so it's
going to be a very exciting discussion
and I really want to prompt the whole
panel to be thinking broadly about these
issues and bringing in the audience as
well we have a great panel that are
going to be talking about their own
particular work and then reflecting not
only what on what's what's happening
today but the potential for future for
future endeavors and for future success
in this area and we're going to start
off the panel with a presentation from
shouting ho shouting is a very dear to
me because she came and helped us out
with our forest carbon markets and
communities workshop in Washington and
volunteered to get up and speak before
our assistant administrator and lots of
people so she's she's a great person she
holds a bachelor's degree
environmental science and accounting
from fudan university and a master's and
environmental management from Yale you
all know her I guess because she's been
leading the forest dialogues forests and
climate change initiatives she's worked
for numerous NGOs and business
consulting firms in China and she's also
visited many sites as part of the forest
dialogue so I really welcome her as the
first panel on reconciling interest at
the landscape scale talking about the 4
f's and she'll tell us what that means
thank you ok thanks Stan for the
introduction and the thanks for the
organizing committee for giving me the
chance to discuss with you guys some of
the most pressing issues our society is
facing today and also share some of the
existing body of work the forest
dialogue and some of our partners are
doing on this specific topic since they
encouraged us to think more Bali let's
step back and the book has a global
context on why we are talking about
reckless reconciling interest and
landscape level it's projected that the
global population is going to surpass 9
billion by 2050 and the continued on the
current pattern of consumption this 9
billion people wouldn't need a lot more
water food fuel and a fiber and the
moreover will consuming more for example
according to the international model and
a policy analysis for agriculture
commodity and the trade they find that
the there will be a new increase of six
to 23 kilogram of meat consumption per
person by 2050 and that is a lot of that
increase is going to happen in
developing countries and we also face
the challenge of climate change local
weather conditions are changing there's
a lot more extreme weather conditions
and those are impact to the cultivation
system and the ecosystem we are seeing
more depletion of soil water by
diversity and it's increasingly apparent
that all this different land uses will
be competing for the limited space and
the natural resources we have on earth
and we're already seeing those
competition at a really intensive level
especially in those growing economy
including China and Brazil this is a
this challenge is actually multi-scale
Montes decoder Montes sector in nature
and it's really complicated question and
the way it involves asking ourselves
what do we think
it's the past that the humanity is going
to take and should take and we also need
to challenge yourself about some of our
worldviews so just stepping way back and
is thinking about the big picture can we
do it all can we save the polar bears
stop deforestation in Amazon forest and
provide from security for all or is it
too idealistic should we step back and I
think there will be trade-offs so if
that's the case how you make compromises
how you map out those different interest
how you prioritize the different
interest what has the models that we
have to do that is incremental changes
enough to address this challenge at hand
and if it's not doing it drastic shift
in the society and the business model
that we have right now to make the
humanity survive this type of different
challenges i just mentioned and is it in
all human nature actually to have those
drastic shift unless some big disaster
big develop disruption in our society
actually happens is globalization going
to help us distribute the limited
resources we have among different places
more efficiently or is it going to
actually concentrate more power create
more superpowers that would undermine
social justice and equality so whether
we should have actually more localized
market looking at how rudee rampant can
be affected in and to encourage more
scaled up localize the market and the
localize the consumption patterns but
how are we going to do that when the
vested interest and the businesses model
right now is increasingly more
international assume that we solve all
these problems there's also a lot of
practical issues we need to address so
looking at the supply chain we need to
think about all along the value chain
how you actually manage this integrated
approach how do you reduce waste all
across of supplying on the and on the
production side a Francis mention
yesterday is land using transportation
technology actually going to lead to
Lance
and if you apply the intensification
technology and the models does it mean
monoculture does it mean more appliance
of chemicals and all these different
ingredients and then how do you avoid
some of the environmental and social
humps what does the integrated and
participatory land-use planning really
mean and how do you do it the and under
this category we also need to think
about some of the issues we have been
working on for decades land rights how
do you have a meaningful participation
based on land rights how do you look at
some of the invested interest and the
current model of top-down land-use
planning and include more local
stakeholders decision in that and what
about ecosystem services how do you
include ecosystem services in your
decision making process and engage other
stakeholders and all this again it's
really a lot of invested a lot of issues
that we haven't we have been working on
for a long time but will this integrated
sinking under this new model of
landscape approach that we're promoting
here provide us a new push to look think
out of the box and create more synergy
and a political will to make those big
shifts happen and on the consumption
side you're also looking at consumers
how do you actually drive change in the
consumption patterns was a symbol land
use we it's really more efficient to
educate the consumers or is there just
way too much information there and this
should be a pretty competitive issue and
you really need to go back to the supply
chain and the look at the big retailers
and actually push the issue back to the
producers think about it whether they
can only produce sustainable goods for
the consumers to use and then again
coming back to the problem of
globalization international trade how do
you prevent the race to bottom when all
these different countries have different
standard and land use and how do you
address issues that was raised yesterday
about when the Chinese consumers the
demand for Chinese consumers for
soybeans is actually driven
deforestation in the Amazon
so all these competitive questions
really pushes to step out of a comfort
zone transcend the traditional way of
Land Management and a sink what we
really can do into with different
partners and with different sectors and
there's already a lot of existing models
tools projects that's out there and then
we already heard some of the projects
this morning I just want to give some
quick examples of what we have learned
through us the force dialogues work on
what are the existing initiatives that's
out there they already some of the
models that can help us conceptualize
some of the complicated problems for
example there's a science model called
complexity science this is basically a
dream rising from the chaos theory and a
lot of more work has been done diet
since the 1990s but it's really just
looking at the section of actions and
the relation between different component
factors and how they actually react to
each other you're more complicated award
and which is actually the reality would
and there's a lot of computer modeling
and the mathematic modeling technique
that's out there help us to map out this
type of complicated relationship and it
counts I relations between these
different things and try to find
practical solutions for different issues
and there's also industrial ecology and
the someone mentioned about the
political ecology this morning this is
also true the right reason from the
ecosystem flow and how you look at
reduce reuse and recycle within
different industry players how you help
the map out of the material energy flow
to reduce the impact but to actually
optimize the outcome and it provides the
environment why don't we actually map
out the material and energy flow between
different land use production systems
and the sink through how we can optimize
outcome and bringing that social element
what you can leverage between these
different stakeholders are lens
skill and help them optimize or what's
the use and reduce reuse and recycle and
and all these different models are
supported by ever more accurate EGR as
technologies and we're not really
talking about the technology only the
educated and the educated centers can
use there's also i would encourage
everyone i'm running out of time but i
would encourage everyone to look at the
extreme citizen science project run by
university college london what they're
doing is they're looking at how they can
actually produce signs that can be used
to buy the majority of citizen and when
we were envious in Congo actually saw a
successful project where the local
village people can use the image
generated the GRS system in a remote
forest in the record whether they have
been consulted what has a social
activity that's going on there and
what's happening with the force so
there's out setup data they can actually
record by themselves and then upload it
to the greater internet and then you can
look at that at a more national level
regional level and the international
level and it is also principles and that
voluntary standards as in the opening
speech you mentioned it is a lot of
different sector sector or sectoral
guidelines that's already there and the
WWE to look at how they can harmonize
this different standard and voluntary
guidelines in those different sectors
and make it more landscape level
guidelines and help people to think
through that how they can work together
according to those principles and
guidelines and the global forest
restoration partnership they have
already come up with ten different
principles that you need to follow when
you implement a landscape approach and
and I I won't go into details with those
but I encourage you to look them up on
the internet and there's a lot of
implementation tools and projects that
we have already heard this is a private
sector driven approach to look at how by
diversity corridors ward
conservation and the different different
land uses can be combined into the
plantation system and the way also this
is this is FAO devoted economic and
ecological zoning where they bring
different ministers working agriculture
forestry and the environment together
and they'll use different sets of data
and come up with the integrated land
planning blueprint and also c4 has done
a quite a lot book the synergies and
trade off between biodiversity
conservation the local livelihood
development across the continent the
force dialogue and the growing force
partnership have recently released a
guide on investing locally controlled
forestry which is based on 17 different
case studies and the three years of
engagement process across seven
countries this is really a guide to
understand how we can scale up the
smallholders forestry enterprises and a
lot of the principles actually apply to
more integrated land use models and also
small farmers operations and the francis
pointed out yesterday it's not really
the problems that we lack information
tools to develop this integrated
approach one of the biggest challenge is
actually communication there's a lack of
communication between the forestry and
agriculture sectors and this is not only
only applies in the government agencies
we also see it in private sector we see
it in NGOs even in one organisation our
own Institute's there's always different
scientists on marine different
scientists on forest and they sitting
the the same building but they may never
talk so we really want to create this
platform to encourage this engagement to
bridge that gap and the support more
evidence-based research to unload some
of the key challenges and share more
information widely with different
stakeholders to communicate some of the
scientific findings to different
stakeholders and make sure that they can
understand some of the practical ways
forward based on those research
and the and this is basically utilizing
a dialogue model that has been perfected
over 12 years of experience it's a
stakeholder driven it's really a mad
resolve conflict developed trust and
then has been proven that chem multi
motivates collaborative outcomes and the
practices I want to go into more details
about that but I encourage everyone to
come to the workshop operated by Gary
downing the executive director of the
force dialogue and he will walk walk you
step to step through this model and when
to date we already done expert dialogue
in Washington DC and another dialog in
Brazil where we look at three land use
models and some of the findings that I
shared here is actually come from those
dialogues as a result of those dialogues
and we've been saying especially in
Brazil with the difference real and use
models despite the different history
there are different objectives and there
are different land use types we found
that integrated approach really help
optimize the outcomes for the landowners
either it's for profit up for personal
pleasure and we will have some of the
summaries or from those two dialogues
outside and you can grab them on your
way out and find them on our website to
anyways i just want to mention that
really the integrated solution start
with you you can really start to talk to
your classmates who do study really
different area from you but those
conversations usually stimulate a lot of
new ideas and that you can try to work
with your classmates who who are som who
are working on water issues and aqua
while working on agriculture to
understand how they approach different
things and then even possible
stileproject wisdom so that's basically
and my presentation and i welcome any of
your comments on some of the challenges
i have listed and ask any questions
thank you
thanks very much for that shouting I
think we'll just take a couple of
questions yeah my folks she she laid out
a huge agenda there is anyone gonna rise
to the challenge okay well we can move
on maybe maybe questions will come up on
during the discussion period now I want
to introduce Jeff stoic who who kindly
reminded me how to pronounce his name I
appreciate that because we haven't met
before but welcome he's a doctoral
student here at fe and s his research is
focused on the politics of large-scale
forest restoration and then Brazilian
Atlantic forest he's a kuhlman fellow
and tropical biology at New York
Botanical Garden couldn't be related at
all to chuck Peters in that could II and
he's a fellow with a national security
education program glad to see he'll be
joining us in the usg in the US
government soon at the State Department
as part of his born fellowship so
welcome Jeff Thank You Diane for the
introduction and good afternoon everyone
first of all I'd like to thank the
organizers of this great conference I've
been on the other side of the podium in
years past and these folks are doing a
great job I also want to note that while
I'm still in the early stages of my
dissertation writing process this year's
conference theme seemed like an ideal
opportunity to discuss some of the
merits and demerits as I see it of
recent changes in the brazilian forest
code
brazilian forest code is federal
legislation that governs the amount and
type of forest cover required on all
private property across the country
while still subject to additional veto
by the president the majority of the
revised version of the forest code
became law last May virtually on the eve
of the Rio plus 20 conference what was
approved was the result of 12 years of
debate in the Brazilian Congress and
civil society
great thank you sorry about that ah now
the debate was very polarized with on
the one hand the so-called rural lists
or agriculture lobby arguing for food
security at home and the ability of
Brazil to meet foreign demand for
agricultural exports and on the other
hand the environmentalists who argued
for preservation of force for
biodiversity and carbon sequestration
for example the environmentalists argued
for a vision of the future for Brazil
where increased efficiency of
agricultural production could meet such
demands yet also spare Brazil's forests
what they called a 21st century vision
versus what they characterized as an
outdated colonial era mode of predatory
agriculture the debate continues to
simmer today as details are worked out
even as the new law takes effect in the
next few minutes I'll outline the basic
issues at play in both the old and new
legislation and how they align with a
subset of my field research findings on
small-scale farmers small-scale farmers
in Brazil's coastal forest now Brazil's
divided into six major biomes or macro
ecosystems Amazonia of course in the
upper left-hand portion the Mata
Atlantica or the coastal Atlantic forest
the central savanna the semi-arid scrub
forest of the Northeast the Pantanal
wetlands of the southwest and the pampas
grass lands of the extreme south this is
relevant due to the fact that the forest
code both old and new varies in its
requirement of forest cover depending on
what biome the properties in these biome
specific mandates are called legal
reserves in the Amazon it's eighty
percent of all private property that
must be under native forest cover in the
Sahara or central savanna it's thirty
five percent and for all other biomes
its twenty percent another major feature
of both the new and old forest code is
that of what are so what are called
permanent protection areas designed to
protect areas on a given property that
are rich in biodiversity or particularly
susceptible to erosion for example
hilltops mountaintops and ridge lines
slopes greater than 45 degrees springs
and headwaters
riparian zones mangroves and coastal
dunes now the forest code of 2012 the
new forest code made several adjustments
and for the sake of time I can only
highlight a few of them they include a
reduction in riparian zones from between
30 and 500 meters to between 5 and 100
meters this range depends on the size of
the waterway and the size of the
property involved another change is that
certain types of cultivation are now
permitted on the boundaries of mangroves
such as shrimp farming the biodiversity
rich and erosion sensitive permanent
protection areas now can be counted
towards a property's biome specific
legal reserve requirement whereas before
that was not the case it had to be
additional further changes included the
fact that small-scale farmers that are
out of compliance are only required to
reforest when T percent of their land
irrespective of which biome they're in
while others must reforest until they
meet the legal reserve and permanent
protection area requirement the question
of amnesty for those who deforested
illegally was a very divisive point
throughout the debate now under the new
law a portion of the reforestation can
be comprised of permanent plantations of
exotic species rather than native
species and finally land owners must
enter their property in the new rural
environmental registry which facilitates
monitoring of environmental compliance
failure to do so leaves landowners
subject to fines and denial of bank
loans returning now to consider
small-scale farmers in particular I'd
like you to keep in mind over the last
three slides of my presentation these
small properties or mini phone juice as
they're called are approximately 3.4
million in number in Brazil and comprise
forty eight point three million hectares
nationwide an average of roughly 14
hectares per property so while small
farms represent ninety percent of
Brazil's total number of rural
properties but occupy only twenty-four
percent of rural land area Brazil's
large properties account for
only three percent of rural owners yet
they occupy fifty-six percent of rural
land area this disparity in land
holdings is particularly interesting as
small farmers the Missouri majority of
which reside in the coastal Atlantic
forest were featured prominently on both
sides of the forest code debate the
rural lists or agribusiness lobby claim
to defend food security interests of the
small farmer in trying to loosen the
forest conservation requirements of the
forest code meanwhile environmentalists
argued the other side saying that
watered down regulations on forest
conservation would put small farmers at
disproportionate risk due to downstream
effects of imprudent land use by their
larger neighbors such as reduced water
quality however when I conducted farm
visits and interviews last year I found
small farmers in Atlantic forest at
least to be largely unconcerned with the
outcomes of forest code debate as they
experienced little enforcement of the
law and were unswayed by potential
penalties if enforcement were to
increase those i interviewed often
maintain forest cover beyond that
mandated by either the old or new forest
code but that being able to work more
land would afford them greater security
without compromising environmental
concerns in their perspective they
stress the need for flexibility in
making decisions about resource
management on their properties they
noted that they derived food not only
from dedicated farming areas but that
forested areas also served as a source
of food for example various fruits and
heart of palm was cited often conversely
they noted that agriculture areas
provided ecosystem services such as soil
retention and many of those with whom I
spoke made it clear that strict
environmental legislation around the
permitting of cutting native species
made exotics preferable for planting
therefore I aim to draw a few tentative
conclusions based on the record of the
forest code debate and the resulting
legislation as well as these site visits
and inner
use namely one that the forest code
revisions appear to me to be more about
rent-seeking by vested interests
including landed politicians than about
purported agricultural productivity to
that perhaps rather than agricultural
intensification or expansion a more
equitable distribution of land allowing
for biodiversity friendly forms of
Agriculture should be encouraged and
finally particularly in the Atlantic
forest a need for agile legislation that
can maximize self-determination in
resource management decisions on
property so with a very few very few
quick acknowledgments thank you for your
time thank you so much Jeff that was
succinct and very informative questions
let you feel the question
I had my problems up here
thank you for question dizzy Hey well I
actually did not intend to study the
forest code when I first decided to head
to Brazil to do research I was more
interested in looking at how
conservation and development were being
balanced in the Atlantic forest an area
that's relatively understudied in Brazil
has a very interesting matrix of
urbanization land abandonment intensive
agricultural use reforestation projects
but I think an answer to your question
was just the timing the fact that I was
in Brazil when this debate this very
divisive very polarized debate was
really just ramping up and I was
actually in Brazil when the Senate
finally approved the legislation passed
it to the President and she did a few
line on him vetoes but it entered into
law so this was very much on the minds
of a lot of the different actors that I
was studying in the Atlantic forest the
as I mentioned the small farmers were
aware of the debate but we're not
terribly concerned with the outcomes
because they saw it at least until that
point in time is irrelevant to their
particular interest but since everyone
else was talking about it I had to
include it in my research
I think she's going to pass you a
microphone maybe how the scientific
community from Brazil has us work has
not supported the forest code or
influence the forest code so since we
are Hina in the University so how we can
what kind of lessons can we learn with
this process in Brazil thank you that's
that's a very important point that I
wasn't able to include in my
presentation but was very much part of
the debate while I was in Brazil a large
number of scientists conservation
biologists experts in the issues of
agricultural scientists as well experts
in the the issues at hand in the forest
code debate got together and had a very
organized coalition to make the latest
science relevant to the debate available
to the politicians making the decisions
in the debate and there were some
meetings between the Senators and the
scientists though in the follow-up to
the the Congressional vote and the
presidential decision the scientific
community was left very dissatisfied
with the amount the degree to which the
science was incorporated in the final
legislation that was proposed and
ultimately approved with a few line-item
vetoes so this gap between science and
policy making is something that was a
particular concern to to those in civil
society and the scientific community in
Brazil
we have a very brief period of time does
anyone have a quick question quick
question okay what I'm can you give an
example of what scientist wanted to
achieve but what was ultimately vetoed
like there are there a couple key things
become one example that comes to mind is
as I mentioned the the permanent
protection areas can now be counted as
part of that total violin specific
percentage a lot of scientists saw the
the purposes of the legal reserve and
the permit protection area as distinct
and therefore should not be counted
towards the same goal the use of exotic
species non-native species in the
recomposition or replanting of either
the legal reserve or the permanent
protection area was something that a lot
of the members of the scientific
community took issue with not their use
at all but their use in perpetuity so a
lot of experts in kind of force dynamics
and forest ecology saw the value in
using exotic species for initial
replanting but that eventually work
should be done so that native species
take over those particular areas thanks
so much Jeff he'll be back for the panel
so let's let's give him a hand
now I'd like to welcome Jonah Bush to to
give a presentation I'm Jonah is known
known in circles in Washington so our
paths have crossed but I didn't know
that he was the lead developer of the
Osiris suite of free online open source
spreadsheet based decision support tools
for estimating and mapping the climate
forest and revenue benefits of
alternative policy decisions for redd+
so this is very exciting to know that
and to know that he is advised on red
plus for many governments for the gef
and that he's published in a lot of
scientific journals and you still work
at Conservation International so welcome
Jonah to the panel good afternoon
everyone I hope everyone's feeling very
food secure after that wonderful lunch
that was both caloric and nutritious
some of you who are second years
second-year fe Esther's here might be
looking at me and thinking weren't you
my mods instructor but that wasn't me
that's my look-alike sister Kirra bush
who was here from 2009 to 2011 so some
of you may know Kira let's see we're
missing the looking at the top
full screen it was control L or maybe
Oh
alright so putting putting this talk in
context this is something this is around
like what shouting was saying we're
living on a planet where two of our
primary human goals are in conflict so
one of these goals is food security we
all want to have enough to eat and the
other is climate stability we want to
live on a planet that gives us climate
conditions that are right for
civilization and these two goals are in
conflict you probably all know this
diagram from the IPCC's fourth
assessment report a few years back that
shows the contributions of agriculture
to to climate change both directly
through fertilizer application and so
forth and indirectly by displacing
forests agriculture commercial large
commercial agriculture has become the
single largest driver of deforestation
in the tropics one of several natural
solutions to this conflict is to shift
the expansion of agriculture away from
tropical forests and there are
essentially two policy approaches that
can be used to do this one is price
based instruments like people talk about
with red carbon payments the second is
placed based policies like protected
areas or moratoria on agricultural
expansion and what I'm going to be doing
in this paper is comparing these two
types of policies and how effective they
can be in a particular place Indonesia
with regards to a particular
agricultural commodity palm oil so palm
oil is in absolutely everything it's a
these days it's it's a fruit it grows on
palm trees like this one and it produces
inside the fruit and edible oil it
produces more edible oil per hectare by
far than any other oil crop it's about
fourth out four thousand kilograms per
hectare the next largest one is all
oil that can be up to about 2,000 and
most of the other ones are far far less
and as a result is quite profitable
because it's and it goes into everything
so you can use it as cooking oil it's
the main source of cooking oil in most
of Asia on it goes into all these
products beverages food cookies and
candy that sounds delicious personal
care products cleaning products
cosmetics so we've all we've already
used this stuff you know by the time we
wake up in the morning and you can even
put in your cars and if you live in
europe europe makes you put it in your
cars or in your neighbors cars a certain
amount of europe's cars have to be
filled with diesel which largely comes
from this palm oil so as a result of all
this use it's growing rapidly it's
currently only let's see palm kernels
this purple wedge here it's about three
percent of global oil production but
it's going up up up every year it's
consumed in China and India and the EU
and everywhere else in the world in this
green here and it's produced mostly
these days about eighty-five percent in
Malaysia and Indonesia and a lot of this
other is Nigeria but many of you may be
familiar with tropical landscapes where
oil palm plantations are going in and
are expanding rapidly this is a picture
from Southeast Asia this is Singapore
here this is Peninsular Malaysia this is
the island of Sumatra part of it in
Indonesia and everything that's in this
this brownish color here is oil palm
plantation and this is actually an under
estimate because this is plantation
that's been around long enough to show
up to remote sensing as a plantation if
it's something that's been cleared and
the trees are little saplings in the
ground and haven't grown yet then that's
not even showing up in this map from
2011 so lots of this stuff what's
involved with with oil palm plantations
primary forest
a lot of it is cleared in the top left
here burned and and cleared just placing
a lot of the animals like in this part
of the world we've got orangutan Tigers
forest elephants some other very
charismatic large species the trees are
put in the ground and these these
planters here and they grow in a
monoculture so you're displacing here on
the top right a native forests that may
have hundreds of different tree species
and about 200 or 300 tons of carbon per
hectare with this mono culture that has
about 40 or 60 tons of carbon per
hectare so this is recognized as a
problem to tell you about Indonesia why
why did we choose this study area the
last speaker was asked why did you
choose you know Brazil why did you
research what you did well Indonesia is
a really ground zero for both the
climate debate for biodiversity and for
palm oil it's the largest third largest
tropical forest some of the highest
endemism and the the fourth largest
greenhouse gas emitter in the world and
they committed in 2009 on their own to a
26 to forty-one percent reduction in
emissions now very very brief summary of
a very complicated land use system in
Indonesia for palm oil essentially the
national and the provincial governments
zone land for what it can be used for
can it be used for plantations must it
be conserved and then the local district
Chiefs are able to grant concessions
which are licenses to clear a particular
area of land for a particular use like
an oil palm plantation Norway and and in
Indonesia signed a 1 billion dollar
letter of intent in 2010 just begin
reducing deforestation with the idea
that more money would be coming later
down the road through a climate payment
mechanism and the centerpiece policy of
this this agreement is it was a two-year
moratorium
on new oil palm and timber concessions
in primary forests and on peatland so it
doesn't include clearing on existing
leases but but prohibits new leases in
these areas that are very high value for
climate on primary for us you saw that
there's a lot of carbon there peat land
as many of you probably know it is a
very very deep watery soil and if you
clear the forest off of it it's like
taking a lid off a boiling pot of water
and all of the gas that's trapped under
there just goes up and up and up to the
atmosphere and there can be two or three
times as much carbon released as from
the burning of the vegetation on top
there's there's a few loopholes as well
that have been publicized one is that
there was a grace period of about a year
between when the policy was announced
and implemented so if you thought you
wanted to go out and get a lease you had
a year to do it before the moratorium
kicked in also there's some area
exemptions that have caused the
moratorium size to be reduced from 69
million hectares down to 65 and then
again to 62 so there's a map with an
area that the moratorium covers and it
it shrinks and shrinks but be that as it
may this is the very important question
we wanted to try to ask with our
research if Indonesia's moratorium as it
stands on new oil palm and timber
concessions on primary forests and peat
lands had been in place from 2000-2010
how effective would it have been how
much would emissions have been reduced
and I had a suspicion that I'd talked a
lot in the intro and I wouldn't you know
be able to make it through all the
different methods so I put all the
answers here just on one slide this is a
three-step question so first of all what
was the potential scope for reducing
emission reductions where the emissions
occur well about forty five percent of
the emissions from deforestation came
from either oil palm concessions or
timber concessions so this is a good
place to start looking it's actually
about ten
son of the land but forty-five percent
of the emissions second how much would
the moratorium a new oil palm and timber
concessions have reduced the emissions
and this is a sort of the tricky
statistical part trying to figure out
comparing land where where concession
was there with with land if the
concession hadn't been there but
essentially what we find with all the
statistics is that putting in an oil
palm concession increases the rate of
deforestation by sixty percent putting
in a timber concession increases it by a
hundred and ten percent so we pull that
out and we say that if those concessions
hadn't been there on those new places
emissions would have been eight point
three percent lower than they actually
were over the period about 600 million
tons of co2 this is this is a lot you
can put it in context the annual
emissions of the US are about 10 times
this much and finally we compare this
using another model this was that Osiris
model that Diane was was introducing
before the talk if they're been carbon
payments instead of of this what would
have been the how much would they have
been and a rather moderate carbon price
of between two and nine dollars could
have achieved the same amount so my my
conclusions from this first way even the
existing moratorium is in political
limbo so the Parliament doesn't want to
see it extended much like in Brazil
they're responding to the agricultural
lobby they say enough is enough the
forestry ministry does want to extend it
Norway is considering putting up more
money for it everyone wants to know how
effective it could be but there's
reasons there's other reasons why carbon
payments a carbon market price could be
more attractive or quick one it could
actually get to the 26 to forty-one
percent goal too if you think about the
political economy it has the potential
to create many many more winners not
only losers if your land I you know if
you were going to put a concern
a plantation in a particular area and
you can't under a moratorium with a poet
with a payment system you could actually
um get carbon payments to reduce and so
you've got a mix of winners and losers
it could be more politically favorable
also a carbon price allows land users to
make marginal decisions it's not just
plant don't plant it's you could decide
well I was going to clear fifty percent
now all only clear twenty percent
something like that the downside of
course is that it requires new
institutions for monitoring our tracking
payments and so forth and so that's part
of the reason why it's attractive to
start with something like this a
moratorium it's easy knowing new
institutions you just pass the law stop
handing out leases and make it work and
that's pretty good so eight percent
point eight point three percent
reduction it's a good start thank you
don't go away there may be questions
particularly since it you know you're
talking about carbon so guys must have
some questions about carbon right
um I was just wondering if you could
explain where the 1 billion from Norway
is going to or is plan to go to if if
not for some kind of compensate
compensation for abiding by the
moratorium yeah thanks and Jeff and I
was we were talking last night he
promised to ask me a really really
difficult question but so I'm glad with
that one um all right I was nervous for
a minute ok so Nord Norway put up a
billion dollars for this moratorium they
have all this North Sea oil that they're
they're burning like crazy and they want
to be a good guy in the climate
discussions and not a bad guy so there
as you guys probably know they're poor
they're they're putting half a billion
dollars ah sorry but you know what is
about a billion dollars a year towards a
tropical reducing tropical deforestation
I've got this this billion-dollar
agreement with Indonesia what is that
money going to part of it is going
towards national readiness so that's
building the institutions in Jakarta and
regional governments to be able to
eventually reduce deforestation that
includes things like producing Maps
they've got something out one map where
they find where the ideas they would
finally have one as its as the name
implies one map of all the forests and
all the different spatial layers that
that contribute that you'd want to know
to analyze deforestation another side of
the money is going towards a pilot
program so they've picked a pilot
province of Central Kalimantan another
one to be determined eventually where
there would be payment for performance
where the emissions are tracked for that
province and if they go down they be
compensated you know on a doll on a
price per ton basis um but a lot of the
money also is just to support this
centerpiece policy of having the having
this moratorium that I described and so
the payment in this case is not
for the monitored and verified
reductions in emissions as it is in this
pilot program it's a payment just to put
a policy in place and so the money is
going to this having this policy happen
and so that's why a lot of people both
in the Indonesian side the Norwegian
side are very interested in is it
effective or not and because it's just
starting we can't really measure its
effectiveness at least in terms of
emission reductions in real time which
is why I try to you know back cast in
and say what if it had been in place
under current rules in the last decade
how effective do we think it would have
been you wanted
yes thanks Jonah for your talk um I have
I guess a comment and also questioned my
first one would be I guess the
moratorium is a two-year moratorium
right and so I was wondering what your
thoughts on what needed to be achieved
within the two years because after the
two years I guess it would be as
business as usual to my understanding
the moratorium is really to give kind of
this kind of a pause in the business
community and also that it's
particularly the government to really
think about what it could do to improve
its spatial planning procedures you were
talking about the one map I think that
is at that is essential and so I don't
really know whether or not Norway or the
government really saw it as a way to
decrease the emissions or more as a way
to really just think about what it would
want to do within the two year plans and
I was wondering whether or not you
thought it was going into the right
direction my second a comment comment
that I had was to achieve the 26 to
forty-one percent emission reductions I
understand it that the National Planning
and Development Agency has actually
allocated various department ministries
for these allocations and I was
wondering what you thought because not
all of these emissions reductions would
only be geared towards a plantation an
agricultural expansion and I wonder if
you knew the numbers for that um and the
other figures of how it would reduce its
emissions yeah thanks so the first
question about you know what was trying
to be achieved with the moratorium I
mean I I'm speculating a little bit but
think back in time to when this
moratorium was first being discussed
between Norway and Indonesia this is you
know two thousand nine or earlier it's
pre Copenhagen and so there was a very
realistic chance that the world would
come to more or less a comprehensive
global climate agreement that would be
involving tens of billions of dollars a
year going from northern countries to
southern countries like Indonesia for
reduced rates of deforestation and so
that that was you know a lot of us were
trying very hard to
make that happen and that was sort of
the context where this moratorium was
initially negotiated so I mean we know
that if you remember Copenhagen that
fell through but and so now we're in
this position and if it had happened
this you know this would have been a
really good bridge strategy of a place
to start and assess whether this market
is really going to happen so now we're
in a position where the you know
essentially those of us who wanted to
see environmental payments weren't able
to you know get the politicians to
deliver on that so there is no big money
there is no tens of billions of dollars
a year there's not even really billions
of dollars a year and so now they're
assessing do we do we keep going with
this this bridge strategy which on the
one hand is is not even sufficient to
get to 26 degrees twenty six percent
reductions on the other hand it's
already a sacrifice that has
agriculturalists pushing back you know
should they continue I think it's going
to depend a lot on whether Norway is
able to pay and get their friends to pay
to keep it going the second question
will remind me what it was it was
looking at the you know there's a
national strategy particularly from
above but not the natural indigo oh
right right right yes ok so the
allocation of emission reductions across
provinces or across sectors so this 26
to forty-one percent emission reductions
is a national target and it doesn't
necessarily mean emissions from
deforestation is 26 to forty-one percent
from transport from industry 26 to
forty-one percent but my understanding
is that if its allocated between sectors
that the burden for reducing emissions
would actually fall more on the forest
sector than it would on on industry on
transport agriculture which are all sort
of targeted to be growth industries
rather than a shrinking you know it's
seen is a big a big opportunity for
reducing like the forest sector so in
reality when you actually start giving
it up the goals the targets from the
forest sector might be even higher than
six 241 thank you so much that was great
um last but not least i want to invite
Peter Newton to talk he is currently a
postdoc research fellow at university of
michigan he studied at the University of
East Anglia and Cambridge in the UK he's
done extensive fieldwork in tropical
forests in Africa South America and
Southeast Asia so she really has a
global perspective using both natural
and social science research methods so
he's cross-disciplinary as well and he's
studying among other things lessons
learned from community forest management
for red which is of great interest to to
our unit as a matter of fact and how
extractive reserves can contribute to
the conservation of biodiversity and
environmental services while positively
influencing rural livelihood so he seems
like a very cross-sectoral person
welcome Peter thanks very much for the
introduction and thanks for for having
me here i'm really delighted to be
talking here so i'm going to talk about
some work some research that I'm doing
with colleagues at the University of
Michigan and at sea caps and in a
project that we have together so do you
want to just tell them what sea caves oh
I'm sorry so C caps is that the cgiar
program for climate change agriculture
and food security as part of the CG I AR
network of which c4 is obviously also an
indie craft also centers I'll be very
brief for the introduction so I feel
like you've heard just three times in
this panel already but I guess it would
get in a point by now so obviously one
of the huge challenges that we face is
how to balance land use decisions in the
tropics with the needs of an additional
two billion people on the planet by 2050
and particularly the disproportionate
increase in food demand and that is
going to accompany an increasingly
prosperous population so on the one hand
we have decisions in forests and the
opposite getting increasingly large
pressures on
in tropical forest areas and yet they
remain as critical as ever the ecosystem
services for biodiversity and for far
less dependent people on the other hand
perhaps we have agriculture and
obviously there's a huge demand for
agricultural space within the within the
tropics you might recognize that photo
apologies if it was meant to be credited
elsewhere so obviously agriculture is a
source of income and it's sort of in a
source of food it's also one of the
major contributors of greenhouse gas
emissions both directly and through
driving deforestation and so a lot of
these challenges are epitomized or
magnified in the commodity agriculture
and see them so particularly with
products such as soy palm oil rubber
cattle and cocoa and so these are the
systems that were interested in the
associated with particularly high rates
of deforestation in fact in aggregate
are responsible for a large proportion
of tropical forest loss and so just as a
couple of examples soybean with in
Brazil soybean production in Brazil was
treble that over the last 20 years and
the and the council increasingly large
proportion of the global totals were
more than a quarter of global soybean
now similarly palm oil has just heard in
Indonesia and Malaysia account for more
than eighty percent of global production
about 50 million tonnes in 2011 other
again as we heard palm oil plantations
and now being developed in West Africa
and large parts of Latin America as well
so those opportunity need to address
some of these challenges these
conservation and development challenges
the good news obviously is that there's
a huge number of people and
organizations involved in trying to
address some of these challenges and
mostly by by instigating or implementing
and developing different innovative
interventions to try and alter where and
how commodity agriculture takes place
and so by intervention in this context I
mean any sort of strategy or policy or
program that somehow it tries to alter
land use decisions within this within
this landscape and so
there's a huge diversity of different
interventions out there we thinking
about these within 3 to the board
different categories and so first of all
we have interventions that are primarily
based on new or modified institutions
and policies secondly we think about
interventions that are based on
incentives which may be either positive
or disincentives and thirdly on
interventions that are based on the
development and dissemination of new
information and technology and so just
give you some examples of the sorts of
things I mean by these and we've heard
about some of them within this
conference already institutions and
policies policies obviously it might
include national policies such as
Brazil's forest code which obviously has
a direct impact on on how land use is
allocated within within the Amazon it
also includes a you know maybe in the
Molitor Iman on pommel concession
licenses with in Indonesia but it could
also be sub-national policy or even in
itself self-regulation within industries
incentives would include funding
allocated within the lead or other
payment of environmental services
mechanisms or could include taxation
strategies as well and information based
interventions would include things like
consumer awareness campaigns to inform
people of make people more aware of the
environmental impact of their purchase
decisions or in this case the this is a
training course running in parts of West
Africa by an NGO with small holder
farmers there to make them more where
more informed and have a greater
capacity to deal with the interim to
optimize the opportunities and
challenges that come from the spread of
palm oil plantation within that region
and so there's a huge diversity of a
different interventions out there and so
how are we to know what is the most
effective approach to take within a
given context how do we know what's
going to work where and when and and
wild and so I guess that's an important
kind of underlying question is what are
the most effective strategies for
achieving improved environmental
economic and social outcomes within
tropical forest landscapes where
commodity agriculture is a key driver of
forest
loss and so a lot of fantastic research
has been done as done an excellent job
of focusing in on particular cases on
particular countries or particular
commodities and identifying and
characterizing those systems what we're
interested in with our research and this
project is stepping back a little bit
and seeing what possibilities it is for
extracting generalizable lessons from
different systems and comparing and
evaluating between commodities between
countries and across cases but how to do
that when we know that there's such a
diversity of different actors of
different countries different
commodities and of different
interventions involved so I guess what
we think of is is that all of these
interventions essentially try to modify
producer behavior to modify land use
decision-making in some way and I do
this either directly by targeting the
land user itself or indirectly through a
commodity supply chain and so I first
sort of step with it within this
research has been to develop a sort of
framework for thinking about
interventions in relation to commodity
supply chains and so this is a sort of
highly simplified characterization of a
supply chain and so we think of three
different sets of actors of different
groups of actors who have their actual
the actors directly involved in supply
chain the market actors from the
producers processors distributors
retailers done and the consumers and
they're obviously connected by flows of
demand and supply and then we think of
two other sets of actors who are if you
like the referral to the supply chain
they're not directly involved in it
necessarily but it's nonetheless have
the capacity to influence it and so
state actors so all levels of national
regional and local government and then
civil society actors who would include
we include in our category NGOs research
institutes and commodity roundtables as
a new sort of institution in there in
this setting and then the connection
between these three groups of actors is
is the interventions and so our our
policies or institutions are incentives
and our information and so these two
sets of actors are indeed the market
actors can influence the supply chain in
a different different nodes different
points through some combination of these
different interventions and so I just
want to illustrate how we might map one
intervention onto onto this supply chain
onto this sort of framework and I'm
going to piggyback off the examples that
were already familiar with with you
allow me sir so Brazil's forest code for
example is a optional federal policy and
so designed and implemented by the state
government it's a it's a policy and it
targets directly the land users this is
pretty sort of straightforward an
alternative would be the certification
of palm oil by the RSPO the round table
for sustainable palm oil and so they
bound table oops and say the round table
is a civil society organization by our
characterization here and actually
operates almost by two separate pathways
so firstly by offering an incentive to
producers in that incentive being
increased buying or selling prices and
access to a particular sort of niche
part of the of the market work where you
can sell certified products and secondly
by offering information to the consumer
about the environmental impact or the
history of the this of the supply chain
root of the product of their their
purchasing and then those decisions
obviously filter back down the supply
chain and to affect ultimately what
happens on the on the ground in in
Carmel producing areas so that's just a
couple very quick examples of how we
might map that's sort of that sort of
intervention and so I guess we see
utility and thinking about interventions
that affect landings decision-making in
the tropics in this way for several
reasons so firstly we can sort of sit
more systematically describe the whole
range of strategies across different
commodities in countries and according
to the types of interventions that are
involved and according to the different
active groups and according to the point
in the supply chain where they where
they have their influence and so we're
particularly interested in in the
governance structures and the
institutional arrangements that support
and thanks and that support these
land-use decisions as I guess Francis
was talking about yesterday intervention
is necessary but not sufficient you have
to have the governance and the support
to make them happen
I guess secondly we want to think about
being more evaluative and asking
questions about which strategies are
most effective what enabling conditions
are prerequisites of success and what
interactions between different active
groups might be the most successful and
under what conditions and more
quantitatively and it is interesting to
really interested here the work that
Jonah you've been doing in quantifying
or to seeing what extent we can quantify
and the impact of a given intervention
so what what can we measure about the
greenhouse gas emissions and what we
measure about the contribution hoods and
the reduction of poverty or whether over
the metric
methods for asking and weren't answering
some of those questions and then finally
and maybe we're a little way off this as
a sort of community yet but obviously I
guess with the eye on the target of and
being able to make some statements about
how best to influence commodity supply
change and asking is it better to target
consumers or producers and under what
circumstances are incentives
institutions or information the most
effective method or is it perhaps more
likely some combination of those and so
in terms of our project or interest
where to the building on this and trying
to sort of develop some of this by
creating or developing a network of
different partners and institutions that
are involved in implementing many of
these sorts of interventions and in
building up some kind of experience and
and unfit and sort of developing this
framework and implementing this
framework with them and so we're
interested in hearing from any
individual organization who is involved
in and I'll talk to you guys afterwards
about studying or implementing any of
these sorts of different interventions
within this context and so I hope that's
given you some introduction to what this
little work we're interested in and
thanks very much for your time and it'd
be great to hear your questions thanks
very much Peter a couple questions on
this framework that he's developed
hi and thanks for your talk um just
talking to Jonah last night actually
about how hard it is for some
organizations to do internally their own
work on evaluating their processes and
programs and how hard it is to allocate
funding for that so I think this is
really important work i worked in
development and definitely seen a huge
lack of of really rigorous evaluation
and monitoring but my question is more
specifically I feel like a lot of that
is so contextual so how do you plan to
do that on a big picture you doing like
some sort of statistical meta-analysis
or do you have a sense of what methods
you can use to do that sort of big
picture evaluation that's just a
multi-million dollar question and maybe
he's more than then we can talk about I
mean I guess it's I guess I guess it
comes at different levels and a
different point sir I mean I think to
get as far as a I mean is unlikely to
arrive at some kind of statistical
analysis or meta-analysis of everything
but if you want to identify a particular
metric such as something that's its
greenhouse gas emissions or and you know
identifying the numbers of hectares of
forests that are conserved all the
impacts of of an intervention on on
incomes or livelihoods there nothing
that sort of things is probably
achievable certainly within some
interventions and particularly those
that describes a place-based those that
have a defined site and that's the sort
of those sort of things that were
exploring with our partners at the
moment and it's to develop to figure out
what are the best metrics are the best
indicators are and I don't have a great
answer for you right now but I'm I mean
I sort of we're ahead is to explore some
of those questions
it's sort of do two-pronged initially I
mean how do you model or if this is an
open-access model how do you approach
simultaneity of different projects I
mean how do you how do you isolate
projects intervention strategies that
are going on simultaneously and then
secondarily as we heard from almost
every the middle two presenters a lot of
times the intervention sort of degrades
over time and there's some sort of some
sort of erosion of efficacy or some sort
of backing down from the commitment so
how do you account for both simultaneity
backing down a commitment or
hypothetically simultaneous backing down
so I just got a little more what you
mean by backing down well I'll say the
overall commitment in an Apollo example
of the number of hectares or the opening
of a window like a grace period and how
do you account for those things just
cure I mean I zhadalan no I'm not I
don't know I think maybe this is
something is worth opening at or
discussion I don't have great answers
for you wait and this is really I guess
developed and presenting a way of
thinking about things just kind of draw
them into it into a common frame but I
don't have great answers to to that
question in any yeah I suggested we may
be thrown as part of the open discussion
sure hi I'm Anna her fourth hi thanks
for your presentation he's really
important work I I just want to note
that all those commodity chains that you
pointed out are associated with really
poor diets the you know the palm oil and
the sugar and the beef for export
soybeans that usually go to pork this is
not food security these are the demand
for those commodities are not about food
security there about those comedies
actually drive foods your food
insecurity because they're of the
opportunity cost of growing those for
rich consumers to become obese versus
the production of foods that could meet
food security needs for a large number
of people so um I just wanted to point
that out because of the framing of you
we're talking about foods and then the
need to feed 2 billion more people but
how bring back the issue of diets and
how are we going to feed those two
billion people is it with commodities
like this because that's not going to
get us into a good situation for equity
or for health yeah no so maybe I didn't
know well that question about how we
feed 2 billion people is more about the
fact that so much space is being taken
up by these commodities and is taking
away for us which are sort of food
security I don't think other thing I
mentioned outside of the title of seek
after i think i mentioned food secured
in a presentation or didn't intend to
certainly not suggesting that
commodities contribute directly to food
security in any sense and fact that more
like to be the opposite exactly as you
as you say so it's more to do it but I
mean but commodity production is going
to continue happening for some time
presumably part of the answer then is
changing consumer dyerson consumer
preferences I think yeah I certainly I
wasn't trying to be accusatory um I
didn't think that you actually thought
that way but I'm just emphasizing that
that message needs to come through
because I liked what you were saying
about which you know do we need it on
the policy side and or the consumer side
and one of the earlier presenters at
full force dialogue said the same thing
so thinking about that also in terms of
yeah I mean certifications so that we
can we can understand the ecological
impact but also that policy in an
education for consumers or through
government's might be also about the
health side yes thanks okay thank you so
much let's let's have a hand for Peter
let's bring the panel up okay so we have
waste 20 minutes if not longer to
continue this discussion this is very a
exciting group of panelists a huge range
of ideas and approaches we've heard
about policy incentives institutions
stakeholder civil society dialogue
market supply chain interventions
working with consumers communication and
I think the focus is really you know how
do we get better land use decisions with
good outcomes for forests good outcomes
for the environment and better outcomes
in terms of real food security right and
not not just a feeding making people
more obese and feeding markets that do
not necessarily need lead to better
better quality food we want to conserve
biodiversity and we want to also i think
one thing I didn't hear so much on the
panel was the importance sort of the
overall importance of good governance
and how all of these different outcomes
should be leading to better governance
overall and maybe strengthening rights
of local people so that they can
capitalize on any gains that are made
but I have a tricky question for you to
start off the discussion as someone who
works for a major donor organization
that is supporting both biodiversity
conservation and as you all know our
major feed the future of food security
initiative so you have what we call in
US aid the elevator speech you have five
minutes with our admin
straighter and you need you you know
that you know we've looked at all of
these different options for you know
getting to better land use that are
eaten a chiral resource use that's more
equitable that contributes to better
nutrition that has better forest
outcomes enhances environmental services
and you have an opportunity to say to
him you know to tell him where he think
where where where should you put your
resources where should we put our
resources in the agency to improving
these outcomes on policies you know so
we have policy work we have projects
more research we could do more research
support more research we can support
institutions we could support global
dialogues we could work on empowerment
we could look at where there have been
successes in this area and try to
replicate them we could do you know
visits of ministers across you know
countries but you know I guess maybe
where are the really acute problems that
that need to be addressed we have really
serious um you know potentially really
serious negative outcomes and if you had
five minutes with our administrator what
would you tell him where where where to
start where should you be investing our
resources anybody want to tackle that I
knew you would step up to the plate yeah
the Chinese speaking to the u.s. trying
to get more money yeah you own most of
our debt so please feel free so we're
really pleased actually I I think
through all this conversations and the
projects we've talked so seeing on the
ground there are a wealth of knowledge
in different sectors on how to best
effectively manage their land but it's
really a lack of understanding behind
some of the values and then how to
communicate with each other and then
there's a big great last opportunities
there to actually more collaboratively
work on
sustainable future so just take an
example of the Brazil case that we saw
three different than use models on the
ground and the this small-scale farmer
which is really integrating different
land uses on a fifth less density Hector
land and then there's a bigger tree
farmer so who himself is actually trying
to integrate different rotations of
soybeans maize and into his traditional
ticked on earth not eucalyptus
plantation on his 800 hectare of land
and then there's a big scale agriculture
guy who only believes in intensification
but all this way after we talked to them
the decision-making the thing that
driven the decision-making is their
values the history that came from their
family the big guy who is a father for
his whole life and his family's farmers
they only know about agriculture
practices and you talk to the
agriculture ministry guys it's the same
thing they only knows the way that they
function and then you talk to the forest
guy who does all this eucalyptus
plantation he knows about the eucalyptus
plantation but he is one of the pioneers
who want to test out how to have
integrated and used to maximize his
profits and then you have another
smaller scale farmer who only interested
in pleasure he he likes to drink picasa
in early in the morning and he likes all
this different type of swarms growing on
his lenny he don't care about profit he
just want to have that integrated land
use that make him happy so just by
linking that big scale agriculture guide
to the forestry camp guy ended a smaller
scale guy he now actually after dialogue
started to thinking about oh maybe I
can't use some of my land to do some of
the forest because they can be my
long-term investment it's just this
small saying that you have linked those
guys talk to each other bring changes
and it's not only at local scale when
you actually open the windows and view
the platform for different stakeholder
to understand what has a value-driven
behind
in making and how they actually function
is a lot of interesting opportunity you
can discover in how they can collaborate
together so I think really it's a lot
about communication pushing people's
that out of their comfort zone Manowar
great journey Thanks I want to meet the
guy who has the cash assa first thing in
the morning so I have two answers to
your question one very specific and then
another more conceptual with with an
example but the first one is we are
sadly at CI losing our international
climate policy lead Becky choco who's
been done an astounding job for us the
last five years engaging with the UNF
Triple C because she's moving to USAID
to answer that very Dodger people is
that is that what no well yeah yes yes
don't pose our people is voluntary I
mean she's way but it's our loss and
it's your gain so from a very practical
standpoint she is now tasked to
integrate climate change into everything
USAID does and so that's a big that's
that's great for you and for all of us
you know who support the mission and
we'll miss her a lot another answer to
the question is that Conservation
International and USAID are partnering
in Indonesia under something called the
sustainable landscapes partnership to
basically attempt to address the
questions multiple questions that you
were posing and so essentially what
we're saying is we've got a big ask of
agricultural landscapes we want to see
food production and food security we
want to see rural development we want to
see good governance we want to see
climate results and probably other
things too and and one of the classic
you know tenets of policy analysis is
multiple interventions for multiple
goals and so it's probably unrealistic
to think that there's one thing which is
going to solve all of these rather it's
multiple interventions implemented
together and so this sustainable
landscape partnership it's a it's a
partnership between USAID CI and
environmental organization the walton
family foundation a private organization
that will put a number of things in
place together so one is essentially
carbon payments a carbon payment program
a red initiative that's its payment for
reductions and emissions in an
agricultural frontier landscape to is a
classical rural economic development of
the type USAID has been practicing for
decades that's tailored to be
complementary to a red program so
reducing emissions with within one area
centered around a protected area while
simultaneously increasing yields
designating sustainable expansion zones
in the rest of the landscape you know in
terms of Purdue it in in terms of
increasing yields this is sometimes
mentioned as a way to take pressure off
the land I think Francis mentioned
before I probably on its own it's it's
it's not going to do the job but in
concert with specific protected areas
it's definitely part of the formula so
we put these two or three interventions
in the same place at once backed with
tens of millions of dollars and we'll
see how it goes and if you want to hear
how it's going I'm not going to tell you
here you have to talk to me over coffee
long story so you're you're advocating a
very integrated approach sort of
attacking the problem in one space with
multiple interventions for that's how
I'd answer your question okay great
anyone else want to tackle that question
there sure yeah overhead better oh
you've given us five minutes in an
elevator which seems like a awfully tall
building but it's yeah well I've had I
don't know what that question no one
gives you 30 seconds maximum but sure
I'm sorry I've got five minutes and he's
mesmerized so he's just not okay and so
I would have to get two things in a time
um one of them I think leaning made kill
me of you said that the governance
wasn't mentioned very much in these
talks a and I'm going to get out in now
and say better will improved or modified
governance of these systems
and and certainly in investing in in new
institutions or at least modified
institutions that on the basis that what
we have is is either not working always
as failed largely and so particularly
promoting multi actor dialogues and so
whichever format they may may come
through and secondly and I'm a welcome
back to one example actually indicates
both of these or illustrates both of
these things secondly I guess being
strategic about or perhaps more
strategic where where we act and and
what we do to try and if not take the
lowest hanging fruit then maybe at least
make the largest gains for the least you
know for the most of the least cost I
guess what have you measured that by and
so I mean one examples of the data that
Jeff put up about the distribution of
land of property sizes ride with in
Brazil so you have three percent of
landowners owning fifty six percent of
of the London I guess was a bazillion
amazon so if you so you can target all
these small holders but even if you
convince all of them to do something
definitely you learning made you know a
tiny sort of slice into the part of you
if you find strategies or policies or
whatever it is to engage with those
without three percent then suddenly
you've made a huge difference for
engaging with with a fewer number of
actors in it and I guess a one example
from from Indonesia an intervention that
we've been working with there's a second
largest palm oil company in Indonesia
called nagra resources of entered into a
sort of a new forest conservation policy
and they were sort of bloke code between
TFT and Greenpeace and triggered
initially or whatever I guess by fairly
sort of relentless public awareness
campaign by a Greenpeace but that
eventually brought God to the to the
table and a vocalist this news the
forest policy which at least on paper
and exceeds the expectations of the rspo
and of end of national policy and so and
that's it so that's you know their their
combined area of oil palm plantation is
huge and have obviously a lot of
leverage with an industry could we see
the big guy leading the way then maybe
others will or follow so I guess and
that sort of strategic decision about
who you
and engage with your target and and how
Jeff Kieran insists yep I recognizes a
little bit self-serving to say but I
think funding for livelihoods research
particularly in the Atlantic forest just
that thin little strip along the coast
in Brazil you find kind of a staggering
diversity in terms of culture ethnicity
ecological heterogeneity and these all
play into the factors the stakeholders
that that you're bringing together and
so I think to try to understand the
interface of culture and ecology a
little bit better in in some areas would
be incredibly useful and then to create
a forum not just for stakeholders to get
together but to have the ear of
policymakers and and folks that really
are making these these decisions that
that affect regions of the country the
country at large and maybe international
policy great before I open up I just
wanted to mention a couple of things
that I didn't hear on that were that
came up in our workshop last week at you
that US aid sponsored on community-based
natural resource management has very
good workshop if anybody's interested in
getting the Proceedings of that and it
brought up a really large scale land use
changes that have happened in some cases
as a result of project interv agents but
really took off on their own without a
lot of these things that we love to do
because we're donors or policymakers or
researchers you know 11 that that comes
to mind is the land care movement in
Australia which is farmer farmer led
natural natural resource management
environmental management I mean it did
get adopted by the government but it was
very much a grassroots movement that
spread to the whole country and then to
New Zealand and then to if the
Philippines and then when I was at a
world agroforestry center we brought it
to East Africa so it's a movement it's
not a policy it's not a project another
one was the Conservancy movement in the
mid
yeah nepal community forestry and then
finally this regretting of the sahel
which i'm sure many of you have heard of
which you know did get some policy and
project interventions but really spread
from the grassroots just as a result of
a simple policy change of making on
making it possible for people to own
trees we're in the core is in the past
they could not own trees and so there
was a huge perverse incentive there so I
just want to lay that out that I i think
you know it's great to have money it's
great to do research but we also should
be thinking about what people are doing
on their own in the grassroots what
civil society does and needs to do to
make these things happen now I'd like to
open it up to the floor yeah and try to
I mean you I don't want to preempt your
question but I'd really like to have
questions that would engage the whole
panel and get them talking to each other
Thanks my question is what is the role
how do you see the role of the private
sector on this issue for instance if I
have like five minutes in the elevator I
will definitely put some effort trying
to convince don't trying to put some
effort towards the private sector
because I think they can play a very
crucial role so public policy sometimes
they take a lot of time to be implement
it and if for instance if we think about
a soy supply chain there are only I
don't know four or five traders in the
role they are in the whole world these
ADM only car guild rifles and some
others so if we get the commitment of
them to a responsible production or with
the palm oil I don't know what are the
companies but I think that's very that
could be very strategic so my question
to you is how do you see the role of
private sector on on achieving a more
sustainable development or
Oh since the fourth dialogue was
established exactly actually to breach
the private sector and NGOs and it was
first started in the forest sector and
we we we did that is especially because
we realized the critical role that the
private secretary actually play in this
policy room and then just meet in the
reality sometimes the politicians do
react better to private sector
interventions then some of the the NGOs
and scientific research is also just a
sad fact but then we also are thinking
more of the ways that we need to
communicate better to the politicians
but in reality private sector has the
strongest for right now and then there's
a lot of different things that we are
looking at with the 4f partnership we
are trying to creating and one of the
biggest thing we're also trying to get
in not only the forest private sector
which already is quite actively involved
with our network with NGOs and the
government and the other different
organizations under the for the force
dialogue network we are also reaching
out to the agriculture private sector
and looking at how we can actually
leverage their power because the the key
first step is actually to identify how
you can attract them the private sector
to being on that work to have the
incentive for them to understand better
for example the agriculture sector I'm
stand a battery or how the forest sector
is is acting and frankly the reason that
there's not that much private sector
involvement from agriculture side is
that this isn't that coffee incentive
for them actually to reach out so we are
working with our partners really to find
that the leverage that we can get a
private sector to act so I think that's
actually more difficult than just
thinking about how the private sector
can act to change the supply chains more
difficult identify that points that you
actually leverage them to work with you
but having said that there's a lot of me
I think there's a new encouraging sign
that the agriculture is reaching private
sector is reaching out and
a new members to the World Business
Council for sustainable development
there's more agricultural companies that
has joined so slowly and slowly we're
seeing the movement towards the private
sector reaching out and I also encourage
you to read a book called the timber
it's looking at in the private sector
side who in the private secretary yet
you actually look at Anna leverage first
to be more effective because you have
private sector producers suppliers and
all the other different people producing
different services and products so there
can in the book of the conclusions you
need to actually target to the retailers
the bigger retailers are like IKEA like
Walmart because they actually have a
wider cast-off network two different
producers so if you target them first
there will be a chain of action along a
lot of producers in different countries
and those big retailers actually has a
huge linkage with government and the
economy for example in China IKEA akia's
production in sales in china so this
type of linkage from the private sector
and then find the incentive and find out
who you actually inference first is
actually the first question I think when
you do
so I'm a little bit out of my expertise
because I don't work on this but I have
colleagues that do and what they say is
to look at something called the consumer
goods forum which is an industry group
of some of the biggest retailers and
though in the world across industries
this is you know McDonald's and as you
mentioned Walmart ikea I mean the big
ones controlling hundreds of billions of
dollars of trade and they made a
commitment that by 2020 their supply
chains for four or five commodities
would be completely free of
deforestation so this is beef soy oil
palm timber paper I believe and so this
you know if it happens or if they even
try to make it happen is going to have
big effects on deforestation in the
tropics is this isn't one little niche
company saying you know we'd like to to
source from you know a village which
meets our our standards of certification
this is you know large percentages of
the entire export of countries that that
if they're going to sell to this group
has to be without deforestation and so
you that means you get interventions at
the scale of entire countries like as I
understand it in the Brazil soy
moratorium which has been one of the big
reasons why brazil's deforestation has
fallen more than eighty percent from its
high about a decade ago was because the
Brazilian government said we've realized
this is the problem is the southern
amazon now the metagross a little bit
different than where we're looking at
before we're going to monitor every
farmer's fields by satellite if they
expand your you're cut off from the
access to market the rural credit this
is a subsidized industry and so
deforestation gone down down down down
down they did that because of the
pressure from their their buyers and the
buyers did it because they face the
public and the public was saying we
don't want deforestation
in the products that we're buying so
that's aw you know that's kind of the
the elevator pitch but please go look at
that forum and see what they're doing
and see if that sounds right just want
to mention that we're already involved
in that we're talking about that at
lunch and the key question there is
going to be you know who defines
deforestation and net deforestation and
even you know what the result is going
to be in the winners and losers and all
of that so it's going to be really
important to pay careful attention to
how that's framed that did someone you
want to follow up somewhat on Jonas
point and it doesn't speak precisely to
your question of how to engage the
private sector but I think in the
context of the forest code and this this
day at this debate that's been going on
for 12 12 years now resulting in the new
forest code was largely seen to be
initiated by an increase in public
concern in Brazil and therefore
certification and and concern on the
part of lenders particularly the
Brazilian national development bank that
they are giving agricultural credit only
to rural land holders that are not
deforesting and so then that led the
agriculture lobby to take an interest in
watering down the the forest code so
there are some unforeseen impacts of of
these particular mobilizations mmm I
mean I don't have huge mantle addict the
balance is an excellent job of answer
garlic but I completely agree i think
engaging a fiver sector is critical i
guess maybe the one thing that hasn't
been mentioned so much is obviously the
emergence of the commodity roundtables
and their progress towards certification
has not always been as fast as some as
we might have liked but I mean and it
obviously can get there if you look at
FSC or something which is obviously you
know super well established now so
perhaps they have to have a good
trajectory obviously you know it's
working better in some places and others
but very quickly okay because I want to
leave time for one more question one
other thing is also like for researchers
and the people who is walking with the
business model just look at how
you switch the material production to
more service eccentric private sector
business model that actually make profit
like switching from producing paper to
how you actually interact with people
the paper company can maybe actually
have more advanced way to provide
services instead of a material so that
would actually have a quiet
transformational changing the
consumption patterns for people so
that's something that the researchers
and the private sector can look together
how to move on material it cannot
economy as we have now to a more
service-oriented one yeah good point
okay Jacques do you wanna one more
question yes so you better make it good
nah just kidding oh yeah but it's big
it's big okay so this is a scientific
conference we are committed to signs we
love science and at least Joan Arlo
signs from union of concerned scientists
are available from from Cuba and Peter
proposed a very sophisticated modern
open access to put you know all the
signs that we can use you know to
address all those issues together but
don't we actually already have this
model maybe not in a computer but in the
brain of a series of people I mean if we
put a bunch of people committed to these
issues and having their own expertise
around the table and they argue and they
make decision isn't that your model
running but then how to transfer that to
policy so is that all about science or
is it about politics but critics in the
wrong way so once we get the signs where
do we get should be should we be
scientist I mean politician they don't
run this model they defend some
particular interest of groups of people
who are going to lobby with them so how
do we shift from the good signs to the
good politics should we be scientists do
more signs or should we be activists
getting the science which is already
there and pushing it on the agenda
should we do both
should we combine the two things I was
actually gonna ask a very similar
question so it's a good it's a hard one
but particularly since we do love
science yeah we love science I've been
told there's a lot more of these pins
for anyone wants this yeah so I can
speak a little bit of the role that I've
tried to play for the last five years as
someone as a scientist in the Science
Division of a non-governmental
environmental mission-driven
organization and so I've had the
privilege to be involved with the UN
climate negotiations and the some of the
decisions taking place in Indonesia and
other tropical countries the role that
that I've I've tried to to play is to
help a decision maker answer what will
be the results of this policy that I'm
considering or I have a goal there's
multiple approaches that could get me
there what are the what will the results
of that be and so there are certainly
many people around the table discussing
all very knowledgeable ah but what I've
seen you know the reason I feel I have a
place that some of those tables would be
to give this answer like eight percent
emission reductions you know you we're
talking about this moratorium lots of
pros lots and cons from all sorts of
things but if someone wants to know is
this going to cut emissions you need a
model for that and the model should be
based on the the soundest possible
science and sometimes it exists and so
you know a consultant can just take an
existing model and run it and give an
answer and that happens a lot but
sometimes the models don't exist and so
somebody has to build the models to be
able to answer that question that's on
the minds of the decision-makers so they
have you know can make an informed
decision and in you know in our country
where we're privileged we have all these
universities there's lots of
universities can do this governments
have research centers in the countries
where we work often times those
resources are fewer and they're in
higher
for other things so we're able to
provide a service by doing some of this
public policy modeling to make informed
choices so that's how I I see our role
as scientists within a mission-driven
organization in the field of essentially
reconciling forest climate agriculture
goals any other quick reflections on
that issue how do we maybe how do we use
science I mean maybe just completely
agree with Jono and maybe just to back
that up but yeah saying that I guess I
mean sure yeah we're all scientists but
a scientist can have many faces of all
the several different scientists have
different faces and the thing is there
were many different roles that we can
feel along a spectrum from more research
oriented to more policy advocacy and
where we each individually fit along
that spectrum I think depends very much
on our own interests our own strengths
and the institutions within which we
work so I don't think there's only one
clear answer and I'm just quickly again
like I feel like is a dialog model that
we've been doing for the four for twelve
years has been quite effective actually
to actually sit down the politicians and
the scientists people who speak really
different language and actually have
them actively listening to each other
and understand where they come from
instead of just reading from a
scientific paper so the power offer
actually the real dialogue is quite
powerful here and then just starting
with even the students here we're in
academia we're learning in a university
but some of the classes can really be
designed to help people understand the
different language we use as a
businessman as a politician as a
scientist so to that and I also want to
encourage everyone to come to the
workshop we're conducting this afternoon
because we're talking about new class
we're designing exactly to help people
understand the different language in
different sectors can I just okay I'm
since i'm moderating i'll get the last
word and which which enables me to bring
in social science and social science is
part of science so understanding
behaviors attitudes values processes
like the kind of
this sees that you're rolling out is
something that really needs to be
rigorously studied and then the results
of that used fed back into policy often
we see that is if people think of that
oh that's process you know and they
don't understand that it really is part
of science so let's integrate and move
on and I want to thank our panel was
great we had a lot of great problems
that have been presented but a lot of
very interesting and compelling
solutions so and thank you all for your
for your questions and we'll see you
this afternoon in various sessions